my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means people hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel i have blood in my hair
it is what it is feel the need to
address it before i get a million
questions
there'll be a link in the description if
you want to find out more about that
otherwise i got to attend summer game
play days recently which was um
sort of like a thing that used to exist
at e3 called judges week where basically
a whole bunch of media i think some
content creators
were able to play a whole bunch of games
that were featured
in this instance at jeff keeley's summit
game fest showcase and so while i
normally take a bunch of questions about
a whole broad array of gaming topics to
answer here every month i decided to
specifically do this one about sonic
frontiers i took a bunch of questions
from you guys on instagram and on
twitter about it and i want to first say
that
the demo that i played was
um
the single worst demo that i've ever
played of any video game for technical
reasons i'm not really sure how this
came together
but at summer game fest sonic was the
only game that you weren't allowed to
record footage of
um on the second day i believe they
actually moved a bunch of plants to try
to stop people from recording the
screens it was the only game that you
weren't allowed to it also had an nda
only game that had an nda uh which is a
bummer because it means i can't talk
about the one thing that i actually
liked about it the most um it's a real
shame there's one thing about it that i
really really liked and that thing is
specifically nda which is such a bummer
but yes technically um as somebody who's
been in the games industry for
11 years now the worst demo i've ever
played it was very strange i almost felt
bad for them um
i
sit down to play the game and it is
windowed uh in that you can literally
see the border like there is a
gray box around with a little x in the
corner and i don't remember what the
title was it didn't say sonic frontiers
but there was some sort of
like i said a border very strange um
the game was so pixelated that it didn't
look anything like the gameplay that i
have in the corner right now somebody
asked me if i saw the rain
and i said
i couldn't even tell if there was rain
it was so pixelated it may as well have
always been raining had really bad frame
rate drops just terrible compression and
uh one thing that made it very difficult
to preview
was that they gave us playstation 4
controllers but all of the prompts were
for an xbox controller which is
confusing even when you're using the
right controller if you swap between all
the consoles but when you're using a
controller that isn't the same as the
prompts on screen even worse yeah really
did my head in so it ran very poorly it
looked terrible it was awkward to play
and those are all technical issues that
don't actually pertain to the game i
think they pertain to the demo itself
the team wasn't ready for it they ran
into hiccups it's stuff that i have a
lot of sympathy for i'm sure that they
you know really would have preferred not
to have to have shown it in that
condition um sometimes it just happens
and it sucks and i also don't believe
that was consistent for everyone uh as
is with a lot of tech issues i think
that some of the other people who
previewed it did not have the same
extremely negative experience that i had
i know some definitely did i spoke to
ralph or skill up about it and it sounds
like he had a very similar experience to
me but definitely some other people did
not uh have that so i feel like i needed
to give that context before i talk about
the game just to say this is the
environment under which i played this
which is very bad and obviously is going
to inform how i feel about the game
outside of that difficult to look at it
for what it is when you're dealing with
a lot of tech issues so to the questions
first one is my only question is does
sonic frontiers feel empty um
i didn't feel like the open world felt
empty
there was a lot to do and a lot of
different uh kind of systems for a lot
of those things and i certainly got the
impression that there were certain
things that i would not yet be able to
do until i unlocked a certain ability um
you come across these bosses in the open
world which i actually found to be
pretty cool and creative and different
um there are also we saw it earlier in
this video that's playing um just a
bunch of like random floating there's
one there just a bunch of random
floating like inexplicably just floating
wires things to
glide on um and they're kind of
everywhere and will lead you in
different directions there are
some curious puzzles scattered around
these little hoops that you kind of fly
through um so now i didn't feel that it
felt empty instead i would say
i think
the biggest issue with sonic frontiers
in terms of this open world is that it
lacks personality it looks like they
were inspired by a bunch of other things
and thus it comes across as very generic
um it does it doesn't have a lot of
mystique to it it really just sort of
feels like a weird kind of sandbox tech
demo that that would be the thing that i
would criticize it for the most heavily
is the open world lacks
a distinct compelling personality um it
really is just a sandbox with a bunch of
sonic [ __ ] to do in it i just yeah i did
not find that particular part of it to
be compelling unfortunately this bit of
gameplay right here is uh
one of the boss fights that you come
across in the open world and i actually
really did
think some of them were cool there was
one that when i got to i was founding i
was finding very difficult and i was
trying my best and the um
one of the pr people i guess was like
hey you aren't high enough level to be
able to do this one um but even this one
i found to be interesting uh
you know you have to avoid that spinning
thing in the middle harder than it looks
took me a while to pick up easiest if
you press the head and you do have a
bunch of different combat options and
different things to juggle and you kind
of just come across these open world
bosses pretty organically um and i found
those to be enjoyable both for the
variety and kind of the the sense of
challenge that came with that variety i
didn't know how exactly i was going to
approach each boss they are
definitely different just a nice sparkle
curiosity in an otherwise
um
yeah unfortunately i think largely
uninteresting open world how's the
gameplay of sonic frontiers well
gameplay tends to mean everything but if
we're specifically speaking about sonic
go fast
it was definitely a little bit awkward
but i think that that's because i was in
a learning position when starting to
play it um
you do have a fair amount of different
skills in your arsenal and different
things that you can you can do in
different ways to
approach gameplay there are buttons and
things to collect that will move the
game world forward and um
these little fires that you're seeing
here you um yeah draw these little
tracks around uh you can use those in
combat too which is actually pretty neat
like in this particular puzzle which is
just another puzzle in the open world i
think you had to progress through this
one but you can you know circle around
all three of them
and that will open a gate or spawn
something um in this instance it's
bourne something so i would say that i
felt like the gameplay had a significant
amount of variety especially compared to
your usual sonic
um
but i think that the variety very much
slowed it down in the open world and
made it have a little bit less of a flow
than normal um but i was certainly
curious about a lot of it i felt like i
had a lot to learn there were
consistent new mechanics that i could
see being implemented in
more creative ways and it wasn't just
flip on ring you know there was
definitely
a bit more to it that i did find to be
interesting it is time to talk about
keeps for those of you who don't already
know keeps is a subscription service
that helps men keep their hair if hair
loss is something that you're insecure
about the best time to start to make a
change is now of course not saying you
should be insecure about it but it's
nice to have an option if you are cubes
offers clinically proven treatments to
combat the symptoms of hair loss and
they are delivered right to your door
basically you can get quality expert
care without ever visiting a doctor's
office or a pharmacy minimal awkwardness
maximum efficiency keeps his clinically
proven research-backed treatments arrive
every three months and at half the cost
of a pharmacy and once you've signed up
you get 24 7 care and support keeps has
a full network of expert medical
advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality each treatment
plan comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can connect with your
prescribing doctor about anything
anytime so whether you're looking to
prevent hair loss stimulate hair growth
or just take better care of the hair you
already have keeps has you covered in
addition to clinically proven treatments
keeps also has an award-winning
all-natural thickening shampoo and
conditioner system but why don't you
just let the cubes physicians help you
select the right products and treatments
for you hair loss stops with keeps to
get 50 off your first order go to
keeps.com alana pierce or click the link
in the description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash alana pierce the
disjointed nature of the open world
though meaning that you have to stop and
slow down and investigate things all the
time yeah it just feels very different
to your usual sonic game you have to
slow down in order to look at the open
world and to assess what kind of puzzle
is this where is this going to take me
should i go in this direction am i going
to fight this boss so the pacing of the
gameplay is very strange i think i think
there are facets of it that are
interesting but um nothing that i was
blown away by more just things that had
me like oh i could see that being
implemented in a unique way and it
definitely does feel different i
definitely wasn't as hot on it as some
of the other people that i know who
played it um and again that could be
because my
experience
technologically was pretty poor
but there are a lot of other creators
that i spoke to who seemed to like it a
lot more than i did people saying stuff
like oh yeah i liked it way more than i
expected to so i could be an outlier
there this question i'm gonna rephrase
slightly but basically says is there
anything to worry about for this new
sonic so despite some of the negative
things that i've said i'm actually going
to say no i don't think that you need to
be worried
again i don't feel that the open world
is empty i think it's more just
uninteresting
boring bland lacks personality but there
are other facets of the game that i
think
make up for this that i'm just
unfortunately not allowed to talk about
yet and then i guess they are holding
back
intentionally for um another time and
those things made me you know not at all
worried i wish i could say more it's
such a bummer that they've restricted um
the more positive information from
getting out i think
no i can't say it i can't say anything
that i want to say i'm sorry do i think
that you need to be massively concerned
ultimately no
that is as much as i'm allowed to say
unfortunately what would be the most
significant thing you would change to
improve sonic frontiers i mean while
i've said that i don't think the open
world feels that empty it would actually
be that i would probably put more in it
or at least more stuff that's connected
so that
while there are all these little things
to do on the ground uh and you do need
to explore to find them and you know you
open more of the map up as you go and
find these things i think it would be
nice if they were just some kind of
overarching system that let you just
bypass all of that if you wanted to like
the ability to sort of free run through
the map would be really nice instead of
having all of these momentum breaks
where you just have to stop all the time
again i don't feel like when i played it
it felt super empty but
yeah the answer is still
that i would put more personality into
it maybe more npcs things other than
just red spiky floaty ball
um
to collect and there are different
things to collect it's just uh yeah make
it less generic and give you more
more pathways so while the open world
did always have
stuff to do very frequently like back to
back and it was rarely
actually empty more options for
traversal i think would be the big thing
um and more that feels seamless
or have personality and not just weird
railings just because i think that that
would make that experience better was
the sonic experience better than the
gameplay shown by ign so that original
gameplay uh that we saw from ign as part
of the ign first was
actually sort of accurate to what
playing it is like but that is only a
very very very small chunk of the open
world um where it was clear that it was
somebody like kind of learning how to
play for the first time or trying to
show different things that are very
disjointed and yeah the open world is
just joining but the game is better than
that but that's not to say that that
video isn't accurate that video is
accurate of certain parts of the game um
a very limited part of the game
does play just like that that thing
right there that big pokemon looking
thing is um also a boss fight that i
found really interesting and that's just
chilling in the open world which is
pretty cool so it's i guess it's just
hard to not compare this open world to
something like like a mario galaxy like
just
even like a ukulele just so many things
that have worlds that just have so much
personality in them it's just so yeah
it's just so nothing which is really
unfortunate and maybe it evolves over
time and fills out to have more stuff in
it that feels more cohesive or unique or
distinct but like the qualities of this
open world are a railing a platform uh
some grass you know it's just
ah it's a bummer well sonic frontier is
a sandbox for the sake of sandbox or did
the trailers not do it justice it is not
a sandbox just for the sake of a sandbox
it it um i feel it has more depth than
that especially because uh there are
mechanics driving you forward like you
have to get this certain amount of keys
to open this thing you need this amount
of this to get this so
even when things feel um a little bit
disjointed in the open world you do have
objectives that would lead you towards
okay i need to go do this so i can get
the second key so i can open this
to make progress so the open world
doesn't feel like sandbox for the sake
of sandbox in that it does have progress
and as you unlock more abilities because
there's a skill tree effectively you'll
get better you will fight better bosses
and i guess
get better rewards so it does not feel
pointless and i think maybe the gameplay
undersold it there but again i was not
impressed by it either i just understand
it a little better now do you think the
sonic frontier controls feel good in
general like running around the open
areas in combat yes i felt like the
controls despite my circumstances of
things being very awkward the controls
were smooth seamless enjoyable i did not
take any issue with controlling sonic
himself
um there's a nice speed boost if you
feel like you're going too slow it's
responsive it feels intuitive so the
controls themselves i did not take any
issue with it all
similar question here but was sonic
frontiers even remotely fun to play
coming from the question about controls
here's the thing i will say and i feel
like it's my biggest takeaway about
sonic frontiers again there were parts
of it that i really enjoyed that we are
not currently allowed to talk about
which
is a bummer and i hope the audience will
you know be stoked when they could
finally talk about those but
the base game and all the stuff that all
of you have seen did i find traversing
the open world fun no no i didn't i
found it to be
awkward disjointed slow there were
things that were interesting and things
were compelling but um the parts that
you are seeing i i had no interest in
really ever playing again i think i
played for about 40 minutes or so and uh
even that no i would not categorize it
as fun
unfortunately
it was something i played
out of curiosity but i would say my
biggest takeaway was yes i was curious
about some of the components but for the
most part
directionless and tedious unfortunately
again except for the parts when i'm all
shocked
sorry i keep saying that but it you know
you'll see you'll understand did playing
sonic for tears change your opinion
either way from what you saw last week
in the gameplay they should so yeah it
did i'm actually more hopeful than i was
originally now that i've seen a little
bit more of the game
so
this is going to sound so mixed because
i'm like i didn't find most of this fun
and i didn't want to play it again but
the stuff that i can't talk about did
make me more hopeful than that original
gameplay reveal did from ign and at this
point i feel like that's where i should
leave it so i just don't keep
talking around the same thing and
repeating myself um so those are the
most common questions that i got right
now it seems to be mostly people
asking the same things
but do let me know if you have any more
questions below obviously it's a weird
one to talk about we want to record
gameplay i'm just showing gameplay from
youtube here and it's something that i
guess i'm very mixed on things i liked
things i really disliked things that i
think are obvious room for improvement
and unfortunately i had a bad demo
experience so that of course plays into
how i speak about it as well
but i'm trying to be as informative as i
possibly can without giving away the
things that i'm not allowed to give away
but do let me know if you have any more
questions if i can answer them
i will that is it for me today everybody
uh if you want to you can also just
leave questions for the next gaming q a
below for the next month so i'll just
answer any of them they do not have to
be about sonic of course because my next
month's gaming q a will not be about
sonic frontiers probably
i also do personal q a's now on my
personal channel i guess alternative
channel um which you'll have in the
description below that is it for me
today everyone i'll see you guys next
time